OK, I have something truly special for you
today.
I'm going to play a three minute clip of Mike
Pence speaking now.
Please don't tune out.
Don't turn this.
I know that that's disgusting, but there's
a reason for this.
Normally, I don't play three minute clips
on the show.
Normally we cut him up.
I play a little segment.
I analyze it, so on and so forth.
Playing the full three minutes here is critical
to understanding the anatomy of not answering
a question.
Mike Pence, vice president, was interviewed
on Fox and Friends yesterday morning, and
Brian Kilmeade asks a very straightforward
question.
The question Brian asked is, is it harder
for someone who is black to make it in the
United States today in 2020?
Very straightforward question.
Mike Pence talked for three minutes, but said
absolutely nothing that could count as an
answer.
So let's just watch.
It's three minutes.
Sit through it.
I apologize, but pay close attention to what
Mike Pence says, because you will notice that
he actually doesn't say anything about the
question that he was asked to.
For someone who's black to make it in this
country, whether they're man or woman, do
you think it's harder for them to make it
in this country in 2020?
Well, Brian, I love your question because
I saw where Joe Biden last night actually
tweeted that everybody ought to have a fair
shot at the American dream.
And it's one of the reasons why, as the president
and I were talking as the president spoke
in Dallas last week, he's made it clear that
while we're going to take a step today to
provide new resources to law enforcement to
help them, you know, embrace higher standards
on de-escalation and the use of force and
and and have and establish an information
sharing.
I mean, you know, as I said, not nobody hates
bad cops more than good cops.
And most of the men and women who put on the
uniform of law enforcement every day are really
the best of us.
We know that.
So we're going to take these steps today to
help improve policing, to help to move that
process forward as a country in the wake of
these tragic events and the violence that
ensued.
But we're not going to stop there, Brian.
I mean, Biden says everybody ought to have
a fair shot at the American dream.
Well, we would say, well, why don't you support
allowing African-American families to choose
where their kids go to school?
I mean, this president has actually stood
strong for school choice.
We've doubled the educational choice program
here in our nation's capital.
And we really do believe that you shouldn't
you shouldn't be denied the ability to choose
where your kids go to school just because
your zip code or because of your income.
We also, as you said, this president, his
policies, we had the lowest unemployment level
ever recorded for African-Americans.
We worked with Senator Tim Scott two to enact
opportunity zones.
Now there's more than 4000 opportunity zones
that have attracted one hundred billion dollars
of investment into our cities.
We're going to continue to drive forward on
jobs and opportunity.
I mean, we understand that the media narrative
around this time and the negativity around
this time.
But as as I sat down with African-American
leaders in Pittsburgh, in Maryland, as the
president welcomed leaders here to the to
the White House and in Dallas, I think I think
millions of African-Americans saw the progress
that we were making over the last three years.
And they know as we bring this economy back
in the wake of not just these tragic events,
in the end, the violence that ensued, but
in the wake, of course, of this corona virus
pandemic that its president, Donald Trump,
who has the prescription for more prosperity,
more educational opportunity and and really
more access to the American dream than 50
years of Democrat leadership under the likes
of Joe Biden has ever given up.
OK, so to remind you what the question was,
because you might have forgotten while Mike
Pence was rambling.
The question was, is it harder for black people
to make it?
In the United States today, it's really a
question that goes to systemic racism, not
about individuals, but about systems.
And Mike Pence doesn't even come close to
even talking about it.
Mike Pence, his answer was to criticize Joe
Biden, to talk about giving law enforcement
more resources, to talk about good cops, dislike
bad cops.
To remind us that most cops are good.
He brought up this tired school choice talking
point, which we'll get to later.
Pence mentions we had low black unemployment
and he worked with a black guy named Tim Scott.
I'm going to come back to that.
The media is being very negative, he said.
I've spoken to black people.
Trump knows how to bring prosperity to people.
And Democrats are bad.
So Mike Pence said 10 different things during
those three minutes, none of which are answers
to the questions.
So now let's go back briefly to black unemployment.
Unemployment is was really low before the
virus.
Remember how during Barack Obama's presidency,
Republicans insisted there are more people
than ever not working in the United States.
And then the day Donald Trump became president,
the same Republicans were saying, we have
more people than ever working in the United
States.
The explanation for that talking point was
or is the population keeps growing.
So at most times, it is true that we have
more people working than ever before and more
people not working than ever before.
Similarly, with this low black unemployment
talking point that Trump and Pence love to
use when unemployment is low, it's generally
low for all groups, again, unless some group
is particularly unaffected by things going
well overall.
There was nothing special that Donald Trump
did for black Americans that would lower their
unemployment rate relative to other groups.
Unemployment was just low for for everybody
until Corona virus hit.
So now we get to the real question, Brian,
kill me to ask, which is an interesting question.
Is it tougher to make it if you are black
in the United States?
For me, the clearest way to think about this
is would I want to switch to being black or
brown right now?
Would I be better off?
Would I have been better off growing up if
I had been black or brown?
And the answer is of course not.
Of course not, because I know that if I were
black or brown, I would be treated differently
and I would not be better off today.
We all know it.
In fact, I don't even have to think about
the hypothetical of being black.
I can think about something much more tangible.
I'm an immigrant from Argentina.
I learned English when I was five, moved to
the United States.
I have very white skin.
If I and my parents moved to the U.S. not
as white Hispanic folks, but as black sorry,
brown Hispanic folks, I think would be a way
to say it.
I would have been treated differently from
the moment we got here.
My parents would have been treated differently
from the moment that we got here.
And despite having made big progress when
it comes to race in the United States and
we have I don't deny that.
I know that we would have been worse off now,
by the way.
I don't often hear people on the left say
this.
The United States is definitely less racist
than many other countries.
I've been to a lot of places in the world
and lots of them are more racist than the
United States.
Often these are places that are much more
homogenous and less diverse than the United
States.
The U.S. is not, as far as I'm concerned,
the most racist country.
That's not actually at issue here.
The point is we have the resources to do way
better and we still have major problems with
race.
And the answer to Brian Kill Medes question
to Mike Pence is, of course, it's tougher
to make it in the United States in 2020 if
you are black or brown.
That still is the case.
And Mike Pence managing to spit out three
minutes worth of words while saying nothing
at
all about what
he was asked about